للمره الثامنه منذ كانون الثاني يناير
الماضي يتظاهر معارض اصلاح نظام التقاعد
الذي طرحه الرئيس الفرنسي
وتامل النقابات ان تظهر الاحتجاجات في
جميع انحاء البلاد معارضه العمال
والموظفين الهائله لخطه رفع سن التقاعد من
62 الى 64 عاما في حين يحاول البرلمانيون
ايجاده تسويه بشان هذا النص الذي يثير
جدلا وتبدو الحكومه مصممه على تمريره مع
او بدون تصوير
لمزيد من المتابعه ما هنا في الاستوديو
مدير مكتب قناه العربيه في فرنسا حسين
فياض قنيبر حسين اهلا وسهلا بك طيب حسين
لنفهم المشاهدين لماذا الحكومه الفرنسيه
مصره تماما على اقرار هذا القانون اي ان
تكن التداعيات حتى لو كانت هنالك خساره
سياسيه مدويه للرئيس ماكرون
في الواقع الحكومه والرئيس مترو يعتبران
انه لا يمكن مواجهه العجز في ميزانيه نظام
التقاعد هذا العجز الذي سيصل بحسب الحكومه
عام 2030 الى 20 مليار يورو لا يمكن
معالجه ذلك الا من خلال تمديد عمل
الفرنسيين سنتين اضافيتين اي رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما طبعا سن
التقاعد في المانيا مثلا هو اقل بقليل من
66 عاما في ايطاليا هو 67 عاما في فرنسا
هو حاليا 62 عاما في عهد الرئيس الاسبق
الراحل كان 60 عاما رفعه سركزي الى 62
عاما وهو ماكرون يقول انه لا بد من رفعه
الى الاربعه والستين عاما والا يعني
بالنسبه الى
الحكومه
ما الفرق يعني بين 62
على الاقل على المستوى المالي في ميزانيه
الدوله وكيف يمكن اقناع العمال والنقابات
بهذا الشيء اولا يعتبرون طالب ان رفع او
ارتفاع معدل اعمار الفرنسيين خلال السنوات
الثلاثين الماضيه بفعل التقدم الطبي فرض
هذا العجز في ميزانيه نظام التقاعد وان
على الفرنسيين ان يمولوا هذا النظام
التقاعدي والا فانه لا يمكن الاستمرار
بهذا النظام قد يتعرض للانهيار المالي اذا
لا مفر من ذلك تقول الحكومه ثم تقول ايضا
انها قدمت تنازلات من بينها ان الرئيس
ماكرون كان يصر في البدايه على ان يرتفع
سن التقاعد بدءا من ايلول سبتمبر المقبل
بواقع اربعه اشهر كل عام ليصل الى 65 عاما
عام 2031 قدم تنازل فاعتبر انه يمكن
القبول من طرف الحكومه برفع سن بدءا من
سبتمبر بواقع ثلاثه اشهر كل عام بدلا من
اربعه اشهر وصولا الى الاربعه والستين
عاما عام 2030 هذا اول تنازل التنازل
الثاني من قبل الحكومه كما تقول الحكومه
نفسها ان الذين يتقاضون دخلا محدودا الا
الذين يتقاضون الحد الادنى للاجور لن يكون
عليهم العمل الثلاثه واربعين عاما كما هو
مطلوب من الاخرين بل انهم سيحصلون على
الراتب التقاعدي الكامل حتى لو لم يعملوا
ثلاثه واربعين عاما شو الحل كل طرف متمدرس
حول موقفه نحن سبعه اشهر او ثمانيه اشهر
هل من حلول هل من وسطات
نعم هناك لجنه برلمانيه مختلطه شكلت من
سبعه اعضاء في الجمعيه الوطنيه اي مجلس
النواب وسبعه اعضاء من مجلس الشيوخ بعد ان
فشل اعضاء مجلس النواب على فشلوا في تبني
هذا المشروع مشروع القانون تبناه طبعا
مجلس الشيوخ حيث الاكثريه يمينيه لكن حزب
ماكرون لا يتمتع بالغالبيه في الجمعيه
الوطنيه اي مجلس النواب لايجاد مخرج شكلت
لجنه برلمانيه مختلطه معظم اعضائها يؤيدون
رفع سن التقاعد اذا نجحوا في ذلك تكون
الازمه انتهت يوم غد يصار الى التصويت في
الجمعيه الوطنيه على مشروع قانون اصلاح
النظام التقاعد واذا لم تنجح اللجنه
البرلمانيه المختلطه لدى الحكومه سلاح
اخير ستلجا اليه اذا عجزت عن اعتماد حلول
اخرى وهو اعتماد الماده
49.3 من الدستور الذي يتيح لاي حكومه ان
تمرر مشروع قانون ما حتى فشل في الحصول
على غالبيه يربط البعض ما يجري في
الموازنات الاورو والاكلاف التي تدفعها
اوروبا في الحرب في اوكرانيا لدعم
اوكرانيا هل يمكن الربط ما يجري الان في
فرنسا مع هذا القانون بالاكلاف التي تدفعه
فرنسا لدعم اوكرانيا ام لا هناك وجهان
للاجابه على سؤالك الوجه الاول ان مشكله
اصلاح نظام التقاعد في فرنسا مشكله مزمنه
كانت سجلت تظاهرات ضخمه عام 95 في عهد
حكومه الانجباي الذي كان اول رئيس وزراء
في الولايه الاولى لجاك شيراك وحينها نزل
ملايين الفرنسيين الى الشوارع ولكن الوجه
الاخر للمشكله ان ما حصل في اوكرانيا هذه
الحرب الواقعه في قلب اوروبا ضغطت على
ميزانيه الدوله الفرنسيه ما يفرض اصلاح
نظام التقاعد براي الحكومه والامور اذا
اما تتجه نحو تصعيد اي اعتماد الحكومه على
الماده 49.3 التي تتيح لها تمرير مشروع
قانون ما حتى لو لم توافق عليها غالبيه
البرلمانيين اذا حصل ذلك سيكون هناك تصعيد
كبير في الشارع تلوح النقبات وتقول انه في
حال عدم حصول موافقه برلمانيه واعتماد
الحكومه على هذا الخيار الاخير سيكون الرد
في الشارع قاسيا اشاره اخيره لو سمحت لي
باريس مدينه العطور ونتيجه اضراب عمال
النفايات الذي يستمر حتى العشرين من هذا
الشهر بدات تنبعث رائحه كريهه من
6600 طن من القمامه في باريس وهذا امر غير
مسبوق في فرنسا مدير مكتب قناه العربيه في
باريس حسين